Thank You Jen that's very kind of you hi
everyone I'm Brad boughs and as Jen said
I'm from Seattle Seattle is the city in
the northwestern corner of the United
States we have a lot of coffee we have a
lot of men with beards we have a lot of
tattoos and we have a lot of rain so I
feel really at home here in Berlin it's
great
I work as a front-end engineer product
manager mostly for very early-stage
startups I like figuring out what should
and should not be in a product so I have
a little bit of advice for you now I
just want to clear something up right
now I know that there been rumors this
is actually not about the Apple watch I
know the timing kind of worked out that
that might be what it's about but it's
actually something different making
something useless sounds it's a funny
thing to say maybe that's why you're
here it's not how we think about things
we normally think about things in their
utility we've learned a lot of really
useful things today and I don't know if
that's always the best idea so there's
one question that as professional
developers engineers that you've been
asked this be asked by your boss your
product manager your client and that
questions how long will it take and if
you're like me that's your answer and if
you really like me and then you just
want to tell them to go away you have to
deal with this problem the reason why
this causes us a lot of anxiety is that
we have to distill all the complicated
things that could go on in this product
in this feature and this bug all the
things that could go wrong we have to
distill that down to a number and we
have to turn that number into a day
and we have to commit to it and then
every decision that we make along the
road we have to meet that number so this
is how we solve problems professionally
we take the problems and we put them
into this mechanism that manages time
and we manage these chunks of problems
together to mate to land the project in
Finnish state sometime down the road and
along the way we have to make a lot of
compromises we have to keep saying oh we
can't do this we can't do that because
we don't have time and that's okay I
mean that's that's how it works we where
we gotta make money business has to go
on but the one thing that this does is
it stops us from exploring code it stops
us from playing with code so the reason
I want you to do something useless take
a little bit of time and do something
where there's no deadline where nobody
cares if it's finished this is the
waterfall swing they have been doing
well with this they've brought it around
if different installations in different
cities and this just looks fun if you if
you I would really rather be there right
now
in fact in speaking in front of you if
you write this and you are not giggling
like a little schoolgirl you're just not
human it looks like a lot of fun so what
this is called broadly speaking is
creative coding it's a little bit of a
problematic term because it has a gate
in front of it creative coding creative
coding is a qualifier your creative is a
good thing so if you're not necessarily
feel like you're creative can you do
creative coding that's a problem that
I'd like to talk about that's what
that's what I want to work through today
so the first thing that I have to say is
to don't be afraid I've been talking
about creative code for a while and a
lot of people say like oh that stuff's
really neat but you know it's not for me
I'm not I'm not creative I'm not good at
that my stuff doesn't look good I can't
do that that's okay that's that's really
natural when most of you think about art
you probably think about something like
this it's a really monolithic work of
craftsmanship this is Rembrandt
self-portrait it's exquisitely rendered
he look
like a million bucks he probably I mean
that's probably his way more than a
million bucks so he's worth it looks
like multiple million bucks and if
you're like me you might have sat down
and you might've tried to draw something
maybe you tried to draw this and I'll
admit like I didn't draw that I took
that I googled it and I took a terrible
child's drawing because I was too
embarrassed of my own bad drawing to put
it on screen this is kind of my favorite
illustration of the problem and it's
what you see all over the place where
experts will give you a tutorial where
it starts to go way way way way too fast
and when you're an expert you never you
never see all these geniuses you never
see all the crap that they actually make
you never see their process when they're
making art you just draw the rest of
them so Ira Glass is an American talk
show host and he has a great talk about
this very problem is set as a creative
person the first thing that you probably
have is taste you know kind of what's
good what's bad and you have an opinion
about the way things should be and so
when you sit down to make something for
that very first time you make it you're
disappointed because you know your taste
is working against you you know that
this stuff is not as good as what you
see out there what you like and he calls
this the gap and I think that's the
everybody faces this and the only way to
cross this gap is with practice you have
to take a step back recognize that I'm
at this gap and I can cross it I can
cross it by doing work I can be put in
practice I can put in time I can work on
this process this is Chuck Close he is
an American artist this was in 1968 I
believe his quote that I really like
inspiration is for amateurs the rest of
us just show up and get to work Chuck
Close as an artist that believes in
process he believes in doing work this
is actually a huge painting it's a 8
foot by 8 foot painting this glorious to
behold if you ever have the opportunity
to see it please do each whisker is
exquisitely rendered the way he rendered
the book
as a as a focus diffuses around his face
is just amazing it's a luminous painting
and he puts in the work and he's
actually made a career out of these
extremely photorealistic large form
pictures and you can see his style
evolved he can understand like this is a
man that's showing up to work he's
putting in the hours and he's making
great work I don't know what his first
work started out like but I imagined
that it evolved and he got better at it
and he didn't start out maybe he started
out drawing the two little circles I
don't know so what this when I see this
we like to think kind of culturally as
artists as being struck by a lightning
bolt maybe they're lounging on a hill
somewhere they're struck by a lightning
bolt of sudden inspiration and then they
go and paint the Mona Lisa or whatever
amazing work whatever is an amazing
piece of work but that's not the case
you know they've got their there they're
men they're women they're working
they're struggling and they're putting
in the hours they're showing up work
they're working on a process they're
working I don't long a direction and
when you're feeling bad about this that
this whatever you're making
think about process as your safety net
know that if you keep working at it
you'll get better and the reason why you
want to keep working when you're trying
to make something that great ideas are
really hidden there's a theory that I
really like from Stuart Kaufman it's
about the adjacent possible and this
theory is about evolution we tend to
think of evolution as a linear path
where we went straight out of the muck
to become Homo sapiens that's not really
how it worked it was sort of a lurching
process where one evolution beget
another evolution which we got another
one and by the time we got to that third
evolution it's a completely different
space than where we started and ideas
work the same way if you're exploring an
idea a project you don't know everything
that's going to happen right away you
have to get in there you have to work
you have to put in the hours and then
maybe you'll see something new that
happens we have this in our own life in
startups they call this a pivot and a
lot of times a pivot is a cover for
something else but the classical use of
pivot is that they've explored a space
they see something else is better
that they didn't see before and then
they move into it so if you combine
these two things idea of working a
process of crossing the gap and then
exploring where you are at every stage
you have a powerful mechanism to make
something new and interesting now it's
important for me to say that I'm not an
artist I'm not particularly blessed with
creativity what I am good at is
streamlining processes I'm good at
understanding how things work but as you
see I'm married to an artist this is
amaranth she is a poetry professor and
as such I have been to far more than my
share of poetry readings performance art
museums and all nature of strange things
and I feel that I'm here as an
ambassador from strange lands to share
like how what I've learned as an
engineer so we work on projects together
this is a one project that we did is
called between page and screen and it is
an augmented reality book of poetry I
know when you open it up you'll see that
you have markers there's no words just a
series of markers and the instructions
to go to between page and screen comm to
find the words so we see me in many ways
and when we hold up we hold the words in
our hands and then what these are is a
series of letters between a page and
screen about they're kind of fractures
relationship
and that's been a very successful
project for us a Moran's been invited to
fly around the world present it she does
a much better job presenting than I do
and this is great this is a this was a
lark a thing that we did for fun and
people liked it it's a real book it has
a skew you can buy it and one of the
great things that came out of it was at
a small arts group approached us about
doing a commissioned project which I
mean that we were paid artists that was
really exciting for us because now even
though it was a teeny teeny amount of
money it counts right is paid and so we
started the process with this group whoa
don't get excited
all right we started the process with
this group ignore that and I started to
look a lot like work and we got that
question how long will it take how long
will it take us to finish this project
when can we deliver it like we've got
arranged the gallery space we've got to
figure this out we've got to start
marketing and it started to feel a lot
like work and the thing is between pages
screen never felt like work this is
actually the first demo that that
amaranth and I did I showed her the
library that did the marker technology
she thought that was cool we talked
about maybe we could do a book we did
this where we have a little piggy on a
piece of paper we showed that to a few
people they thought that was cool and
before you know we had a book and now we
have this whole other project and we
have a deadline and it's stressful we
decided to do a project where we had
Diaries from 1858 shopkeepers diary had
told a very interesting story amaranth
abstracted some of the transcribes some
of the entries you know we decide we'd
have a project with the leap motion
where you would go to a gallery you
would see the leap motion on a column
and then you would see a monitor above
it that is not as gloriously large as
this one and then as you approached you
would see your zone distorted face and
when you waved your hand over the leap
motion you would see there's another
text within it this is called an erasure
and this is all done in JavaScript with
with particles so they're about a
million particles that are moving around
around my hand and we have 30 30
different entries that you can go and
you can read
thank you then that's very kind of you
and actually it's really hard for me to
just show that project because I don't
think I don't think it's as good as what
it could be it doesn't have the same pop
that between page and screen has people
went when Imran shows between page and
screen there's a new in the audience and
this one doesn't quite doesn't quite
have that and one reason I feel is that
this deadline really paralyzed paralyzed
me there was a lot of new technology
they need to learn and every one of
these god-blessed technologies had some
problem or another in doing this and
every time that I was faced with solving
this problem I had to make compromises
because we had a deadline that's okay I
mean that's how that's how stuff works
is how business works but it made me
think about this this problem of time
and what it does to the creative process
so with all this technology I realized
that when we were doing the gallery
installation so one thing that people
like to do is they just like to go up
and they like to see themselves
reflected and I thought that was pretty
cool and I realized with this big plate
of software that I had I could do a new
project I could reuse that rendering
pipeline and do something that I call a
glitch booth
and what glitch booth is is it takes
very bad selfies so as you see it's it's
kind of like a Skype call
and there are different things so you
can do and then if you find one that you
like you can well you can tweet it
so that's glitch booth and this was that
was about 10 hours of code maybe 15
hours code I spent more time on the logo
on the site on registering the Twitter
on doing all that stuff then I spent on
actually writing the code and I think
that this is a really great example of
the adjacent possible there's no way
what has just sat down and made glitch
booth it's a little bit of a trivial
project but because I had all the code
line around they made something that was
fun and I brought it to Cascadia j/s in
in July and a lot of people came up to
and took pictures with it and tweeted it
out here's Carter and it was a lot of
fun and you can see that now you can see
all the pictures are about 90 of them
ion glitch booth is it's a Twitter
account so that's a little bit of my
work and now it's your turn so I want
you to make something useless the first
thing that you find as a diligent
conference goer because I know you're
gonna go home and I know you're gonna
you're gonna sit down you can say Brad
wanted me to make something useless gosh
darn it and I'm gonna do that and you'll
find that blank pages are blockers
that's the hardest part about getting
started is getting started do you have a
blank page and that's not a new problem
one thing that artists do is that they
use rules to help you get started
they're called constraints a really
common constraint is a haiku it's a
three-line poem first line has five
syllables seven syllables five syllables
in the United States we have school
children do this because it's so the
form is so restrictive that it becomes a
game you have to fit whatever your
message is into this really tight format
so instead of like giving kids some sort
of blank verse assignment they give them
haiku and the kids get it done and they
learn a little bit about poetry so we
actually have we're blessed with this
enormous network of constraint based
writing I guess you call it Twitter so
this is a haiku bot that goes and finds
completely inane tweets and recognizes
that there in the haiku format and then
tweets them as such they're actually
kind of pretty entertaining I know
everybody's got their favorite BOTS this
one's mine
it's art assignment but it's obviously
pulling a list of three different tasks
the tasks the theme and then a deadline
and they're great
I love the instructor 3d print
critiquing fear due in two seconds
so bots are a great place to start and
the reason why they're a great place to
start is that they're using the the
tools that you already know how to do
they have they're all based with text
they're based with if you know a little
regex
if you can can catapult you can pull
from a list if you can use an API you're
set you're golden and then there's a
built-in audience once you tweet it and
then there's also a built-in data set
that's always changing so there are a
lot of really fun things you can do with
that if text isn't your thing and that's
totally cool this is Saul DeWitt Saul
the wit is considered the father of
conceptual art and he is most famous for
wall drawings the wall drawings are just
instructions instructions for how to
generate the drawing and what you have
here this text is actually the
instructions for the image that you see
behind it that basically says place 50
random dots on the wall and then connect
them all and so if you want to have your
own Sol LeWitt you hire drafts people
official certified Sol LeWitt drafts
people to come out they will put this
all the weight on your wall and you'll
get a certificate and you now own ass
all the whit force all the width this is
a conceptual piece he doesn't need to be
there you never meets all the wit when
you have your official Sala wit
certificate he's dead you can still get
a new solid just for you this is part of
the concept so when I saw these
instructions
I thought it looked a lot like a ticket
from a p.m. and so I made a repository I
have no idea if this is legal or not but
it hasn't been shut down yet
I have several dozen of the instructions
you can go there there are templates
using paper J s using processing if
there's a graphics language that you
particularly like we can we can make a
template for you and people are making
their own renderings of Salta wit so
this is one you can you can go to it
right now and is renders in your browser
there's another one another one another
one and the great thing about them is
that there can be multiple versions of
the same solution because they have a
little bit of they have a playful
ambiguity and he did that intentionally
that different artists different drafts
people would interpret it differently so
I really encourage you to fork that repo
hey give it a start because that helps
you know and then it takes about an hour
two hours depending on your comfort with
with drawing with code and salsa and
then finally this is something that you
can do without any code at all I know
that's kind of an outrageous proposal at
a J's conf PUD that's the deal so this
is a Swiss a group of Swiss artists and
they were inspired by Sol LeWitt they
have conditional Design workbook and
what they have are basically art games
they have all you need are four players
four sharpies and many beers and each
player takes a turn and what you see
there is that they're doing the first
exercise in the book which is a cross
hatching exercise and by the time that
they're finished with it you get kind of
a neat piece of hatched art this is a
great thing to do with anyone you can do
it with your partner you can do it with
your kids you can even do it with your
company your entire company because
everybody will have a different
perspective on how this this art is
generated I did this with 60 engineers
at the company in LA it was really neat
it was neat to head them up on their
wall for four months afterward
that's the conditional design workbook I
love it they have about a dozen
exercises in this book you can download
it
conditional design org or buy it if you
ever see their European if you ever see
them buy them a beer and send me the
bill this is great work and they deserve
to be rewarded so those are some things
to get started it's not that limit of
things to get started we have all this
great stuff like projection mapping that
we see here the demo scene that Matthew
talked about earlier there's Arduino
connect there's just tons of things to
do these are three little little snacks
for you to start with start with
anything and point the reason why I want
you to do this is that as developers we
solve problems for a living we solve
problems through technology and the
technology is going to change but the
problem-solving skills are not so if you
take time to abstract your
problem-solving skills using something
like this and get to really like
understand the process of how you solve
problems I think that's a skill that
you're going to be able to use for a
long time in your career long after like
angular JavaScript becomes something
that new in five years JavaScript okay
is not going anywhere I won't that's not
blasphemy but you're still going to need
to be able to solve problems whatever
happens so go home this is uh this is my
Twitter handle it takes me to my website
my email I want to help show me what you
make and let's get started thank you
very much
you